come on baby
Flores bicycles there's a special
everything a special frame especial
wheels a special paint everything is
special the bicycles we make is make
with love because it's with our hands
you know those bikes snoop and countless
other rappers wrote around in you know
the ones that ooze that West Coast style
lowrider bikes low to the ground chromed
out gold-plated they're an extension of
lowrider car culture and they all
started here I am The Godfather of the
lowrider bicycles when I was 10 years is
to fix all the pipes of the neighbors
always dream with a motorcycle and a car
but since I was too small in no money so
I put my mind in the bicycles a mainstay
in Compton in West Coast culture these
iconic bikes were actually first created
in Mexico I brought the lowrider
to California in early 80s and soon
after locals took notice of the shiny
swaggy riots hanging in a shop when I
started making bikes and put it in a
display people come and and say can you
make me one of those and then they
spread and now we have customers from
all over the world this is one of the
men's creators right here I almost
actually put everything on here blew my
mind when when he put it on here for me
it's a completely different than the
regular bikes and the way they look and
the way they drive
is our people's dream and we make the
dream come true